the fields are flat and featureless but
this territory is critically important
for this is the gateway to Harrison City
a regional capital and a military prize
we're looking to our left over there
because that is the direction Russian
forces are in at the moment and it is
open here it it feels exposed
this is the Ukrainian front line some 30
kilometers from the city's outskirts
and we were taken to see the troops who
live and fight in trenches and tunnels
that stretch for miles
sleep that's where you sleep yo okay
spam
Alexander says cover is something he
needs this position gets hit every day
um
we found Vadim and Anatoly Manning this
post their eyes fixed on the horizon
and they told us they'll soon recapture
more ground
Winter's coming it's going to get more
difficult isn't it
it's like the first world war down here
it's very compact claustrophobic really
people
sleeping in holes in the walls and their
personal effects
are tucked away in little cubby holes
when people talk about living in close
quarters this is a good example of it
there is a machine gun post that
protects Ukrainian positions and the
local Commander offered to take us there
it occupies ground the ukrainians have
recently seized but the Russians are not
very far away you know this trench was
dug by the Russians so they know exactly
where it is
at the end of a shallow trench we found
a pair of gunners
he said they were facing troops from the
Russian region of chechnya
then
um
the light was fading and we were told to
return an order given with good reason
the area was shelled with clouds of dust
rising in the fields
the smoke to the east
the smoke to the South
the after effects of artillery shells or
mortars
I think it's going to be a
a long night for these guys
John Sparks Sky News in the region of
hairson